So, how can employers ensure the physical and mental well-being of their employees...
...when they work from home?
For inspiration, it might be worth looking to the world leader in remote working.
Finland has been at the forefront of flexible working since the 1990s.
Even before the pandemic, almost a third of Finns occasionally work from home,...
...including Kirsimarja Bloomqvist.
And I got a small electronic desk and I have this flat screen before.
And I have a good chair.
And I have a window now out to the yard or garden and forest.
And also, this is my yoga studio as well.
So, it's perfect.
Kirsimarja is a Finnish professor who's been researching remote working.
In Finland, there's a long tradition for remote work.
There are several reasons,...
...but one is that we have a good broadband all across the country.
And then also, I would say that the digitalization at the workplace,...
...so you don't have to take all the papers from work to home,...
...and the high portion of knowledge workers in Finland.
And then another thing, which I also think is quite important, is the culture of trust.
And that is something we also see in our research.
Finland even has a specific remote working law...
...which allows employees to work from somewhere other than their office...
...for at least half the week.
All this meant that when the pandemic hit,...
...the shift to remote working for many Finns was...
...surprisingly easy.